hey what's going on guys it's Rob before
I start today I think I should really
get rid of this so just give me one
second
much better well I guess this stuff can
go too so all right not too bad not too
bad now just for the mustache um oh come
on
really how am I supposed to get rid of
this now
all right much better hey what's going
on guys so I guess that that's over with
I can get to the video I know I've been
gone for a while and I'm sure a lot of
you have you know some questions what's
going on I'm probably gonna put out
another update video after this one but
I know you guys want to learn something
so thanks for watching and welcome back
to today I'm going to teach you how to
make the spiky balloon the spiky balloon
is really cool and it's just like the
regular balloon except once you blow it
up you'll push on some pre-made creases
to get something like this the really
cool thing about the spiky balloon is
that it's heavier on one side so if you
put that side facing up and let go of it
it wants to tend to roll over so you can
basically show people and they'll be
amazed that it's actually moving and
they might not be able to figure out why
let's get started then you can start out
with an eight-and-a-half eleven sheet
like I am or you can use origami paper
it doesn't really matter even so we need
to make the eight-and-a-half eleven
sheet into a square by taking the corner
folding it across lining it up
making good creases while we do so and
then I like to flip it over take this
excess piece and fold it down until I
see that edge and then I can crease it
really well and rip that extra piece off
all right so now that I have a square
piece of paper you'll see I have a
diagonal fold going that way and I'm
going to make it so that I have a
diagonal fold going this way as well to
do that we take the upper left corner
now and fold it down to the bottom right
corner line it up as neatly as possible
and then make a crease on the edge of
the paper
again run your fingernail gently against
the crease to make sure that it's extra
sharp now if you open up the paper
you'll see that we have an X in the
paper what you're going to do is to flip
the paper over we're going to take the
top now and fold it down all the way to
the bottom once it's lined up again make
a good crease and run your fingernail
against the edge open it up now we're
going to fold the top edge down to the
middle line here and we're also going to
fold the bottom edge into the middle
line so let's go ahead and do that
and run your fingernail against each of
those creases okay so now if you open it
you'll see it's divided into fourths
we're going to turn the papers sideways
like this 90 degrees and we're going to
do the exact same thing
so top edge first goes down to the
bottom edge open it up top and bottom
edges go right into the middle so now if
you open up the paper you should notice
that it's divided into 16 squares and
the paper also has two diagonal folds
going across it we're going to flip the
paper back over and these two diagonal
folds that we made before we're just
going to fold on them again and just
give them an extra little crease like
that now if you hold the paper like this
what we're going to be doing is we're
going to be folding this corner of the
paper inwards at these various lines or
points to demonstrate this I'm going to
draw on the paper points that correspond
with the intersections in the paper I'm
going to call this a b c and d the first
step is we're going to take the corner
here and we're going to fold it to this
first point if i hold it up like this
you can see this just corresponds to one
of the squares okay so the bottom corner
here is going to be folded up to point B
the top of this little square
make a crease on the bottom here and run
your fingernail then you're going to
unfold this corner and you're going to
fold a up to see now which is the middle
of the paper crease on the bottom run
your fingernail against there as well
now we're going to unfold the paper and
point a is going to be folded up to
point D once again take the corner of
the paper fold it up until it hits point
D which again is the corner of that
little square so line it up with D and
crease on the bottom alright so now that
we've done that you'll see we have these
extra lines in the paper now I'm not
going to go through with you how to do
that for the remaining three but I'm
confident that by the LES demonstration
you understand what to do we're going to
turn the paper and just do the same
thing with this corner folding it to
these three spots then do the same and
you get the point
I know it's a little bit tedious to do
it but in the end it will help because
you're going to need these pre creases
in order to make the spiky ball and once
you're done you should have a paper like
this that has 16 squares and each square
has an X in it at this point we're going
to take each of the four corners and
we're going to fold that exterior
triangle in just like that so just on
that first little square fold on that
crease that we made do that for all four
corners okay now we're going to take the
top of the model and fold it down to the
bottom of the model on this horizontal
crease
take the top and fold it in half now as
you'll see I've drawn some lines up to
make sure this goes underneath like that
I've drawn some lines on these creases
here these are the creases that we're
going to need to fold in order to make
the waterbomb base if you haven't made
the waterbomb I would recommend you try
that first because it will make things a
lot easier you're going to open these
two side flaps these two edges and
you're going to tuck this corner in
towards the middle on those two creases
I'm going to push it in and then squeeze
these two edges together do the same
thing with the other side take it open
these two edges and then push right
there and squeeze and there you go at
this point if you folded it correctly
you should have something that looks
like this and each of those corners that
you fold it in should be at this point
in between these folds in the paper now
you'll notice you have two top flaps and
two bottom flaps we're going to start
with the top right flap here this little
point right here that I'm pointing to is
going to be folded over here to a
certain point right here now I'm going
to draw another line so that you can see
exactly what I'm talking about this
point on that diamond
is going to meet that point so what you
need to do is you need to take this and
you're going to fold it so that that
point lines up with that point that I
drew in the paper and you're going to
make a crease so as you'll see it
actually folds directly down these
diamonds here once you have the paper
like that you're going to take this
point and you'll see this little
triangle that's sticking up you're just
going to fold this little triangle back
to the right like that now you can hold
everything down and if you look at the
model you'll notice that there's a small
little pocket right here in the paper
you want to open that pocket and you see
this little triangle here this little
piece of paper you need to fold this
paper into that pocket to do that
set it down fold this little triangle up
make a crease unfold it and then what
you can do is open up this little pocket
and you can fold that little piece of
paper inside that is how you interlock
one of the corners of the paper now we
have to do the same with the remaining
three so to start with the other one the
first corner got sent to here this
corner goes to here meaning it's going
to be folding along this line right here
okay so take the top flap only fold it
across to this point
and make a crease okay now I'm going to
take this little triangular portion and
just fold it back to the left like that
and once again take this little
triangular piece this little flap and
I'm going to fold it up make a little
crease open up this pocket here and you
can tuck that corner of the paper right
into that little pocket okay so now that
we've done - all we need to do is to
flip it over to do the other two and
then we're done once we flip the model
over it's basically the same exact thing
so I'm going to take this point bring it
right to here
you'll also notice that when you fold it
over this crease will line up with the
crease behind it here on the back flap
so they should line up so that one goes
there take the tip fold it back until
the tip is basically on that edge and
then give it another good crease once
again you could fold this little corner
upwards
open up the pocket and slide that in
once again take the last one fold it
over to the same point give it a crease
fold the point backwards and then crease
that fold the triangle up open the
pocket right in there and then you can
tuck that corner right into the pocket
and give it a good squeeze and there you
go that's the finished model and as
you'll see it has a little opening here
what you want to do is to grab two
opposite ends of the spiky balloon and
you're going to pull it apart just
gently so that you see a little opening
here you're then going to blow into the
opening while pulling apart gently okay
so now you'll see it is inflated and as
you'll see each part of the balloon has
a diamond in it and what you're going to
be doing is you're going to pushing on
the valley folds that you made within
each of those diamonds so you'll see
it's it's really not that hard you're
basically just pushing on each of these
diamonds and trying to find that Valley
fold you may get a little bit of
crinkling but hopefully we can fix that
big I'm not so bad okay there we go
so it is a little bit tricky I died I
won't deny it
I call this an intermediate model and
there you go that is the spiky balloon
so I'd like to really thank you guys for
watching the video and for staying
subscribed to my channel I hope it was
helpful and I hope you enjoyed it if you
did like the tutorial please click the
like button down below I'd really
appreciate it and leave me some feedback
and let me know what you thought I know
it
kind of tough with me getting videos out
so rear so kind of rarely recently but
I'm really trying to change that I'd
like to get a video out every two weeks
that's my goal I don't know you know if
it's going to happen yet but that's what
I'm really shooting for I'm not giving
up on YouTube obviously I really loved
the just the interaction I get to have
with you guys and being able to show you
some things which you may not be aware
of where you've never seen before you
know something cool to kind of entertain
you while you have some free time don't
forget as far as the paper balloon this
but I'm sorry if the spiky balloon is
concerned you're going to hold the part
that has the hole in it on top and it
will roll Lila did you see what I just
made it's called a spiky balloon and you
could probably rub your head against it
if you get itchy
so okay Lila so you want to thank
everyone for for watching the video you
say thank you
Lila say thank you alright I guess that
does it